What do you think about
deuterium related to illness and disease
and can deuterium depletion help us?
Wow, good question.
So deuterium is oxygen with an extra hydrogen on it.
And deuterium is in all of our water supply.
A percentage of our water is deuterium.
They're really interesting studies on deuterium.
Societies, or you could say cultures,
that drink water that has less deuterium in it,
live longer across the board.
They live longer.
Why is that?
Deuterium is heavy water, it's called heavy water.
And it doesn't function in our body as water.
And it can block water's function in our body.
So you can actually buy deuterium depleted water.
So what are the societies that drink water?
Where is water that has less deuterium in it?
Every all of our water throughout this entire planet
has deuterium in it.
But there's some water that has less deuterium in it.
And that is water that's melted from glacial water.
There is a bottled water company called Icelandic.
You've heard of Icelandic water.
They might sell it in the grocery store.
They might sell it at a gas station.
Comes in a kind of a square bottle with ridges on it.
It is naturally deuterium depleted water.
It has a lower content of deuterium in it.
And really, there can be benefits to drinking Icelandic water.
So deuterium depleted water, you could actually buy.
There's a process where you could deplete deuterium in the water.
It's just quite expensive.
And there's been studies where people have used deuterium depleted water
with cancer.
And some that people have gotten better
just using deuterium depleted water.
It can't be difficult to get.
You have to order it, I think from overseas.
I don't think there's a place in the US that makes it.
But it's, but you can get slightly deuterium depleted water
with Icelandic water.
That's one thing I did talk about.
What do you do with your cancer?
What about a bug I drank Icelandic water?
And then we had it on order.
You could order it on Amazon.
We had it just out of delivery.
So probably a couple of months that we were drinking Icelandic,
which is slightly deuterium depleted water.
I don't remember the numbers of the scale.
I'd have to look that up.
But there can be benefits to deuterium
both depleted water sources.